hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host John Carroll and
today's topic is Insurance markets now I
know in the history of mindscape we've
talked about the meaning of life the
fundamental laws of physics the way that
giant philosophical scientific ideas fit
together as well as some more fun Arts
and Cultural kind of topics compared to
our usual Affair Insurance markets seem
pretty down to earth maybe not the
sexiest topic depending on what you get
interested in I get that but let me tell
you when you dig into what an insurance
Market is and why it might not work it's
fascinating there's a lot of
intellectually interesting things going
on here especially if you care and or
are interested in the fundamental
workings of capitalism and the market so
not to sort of spoil too much of the
conversation to come but the basic idea
is very simple like what is insurance
insurance is a trade you give somebody
money now for Peace of Mind basically
for knowing that if something goes
terribly wrong you'll be able to protect
yourself to cover your debts or whatever
it is depending on the kinds of
insurance so it's already intellectually
interesting because it's trading
something right now for a future thing
which is always kind of a an interesting
question but there's also the question
of the market for insurance and how it
works and how it's a sort of counter
example to many things that capitalism
is supposed to do we know the capitalist
markets can fail for various reasons
that there are monopolies or monopsonies
and things like that incomplete
information but here's an insurance
market failure if you offer Insurance to
a bunch of people
and you say okay if you get sick I will
pay for your health care and you set a
certain rate and guess what who buys
your insurance the people who are likely
to get sick the people who are more
healthy are less likely to buy the
insurance so you have been very careful
you had done some Actuarial tables you
figured out how often people get sick
you knew that you would make money if
you bought your insurance you failed to
make money because only the sick people
bought your insurance so you go ah okay
so it's only the sick people are going
to buy it what I need to do is to raise
my prices
so that I can still make money even if
only the sick people buy my insurance
but then guess what only they're really
sick people buying insurance so there is
a race to failure built into the very
nature of an insurance market and it's
not because people are greedy it's not
because the giant establishment is out
to get you it's just that supply and
demand isn't really working it's not
about fairness it's just about the
mechanism not quite working how do you
fix that right uh there's a whole
literature on this phenomenon about
adverse selection where buyers and
sellers have different information and
buyers in particular have private
information about how sick they are for
example what bad thing is going to
happen to them still to this day there's
no such thing as divorce insurance
because the buyer is going to know much
better than the seller whether they're
likely to get divorced very soon so
today's guest is Amy Finkelstein who's a
very well respected Economist at MIT and
she and her collaborators recently wrote
a book risky business why Insurance
markets fail and what to do about it so
I like a topic because it's at the
intersection there of real world stuff
that really matters you know legislation
and things like that how we organize our
system but also there's interesting
intellectual questions about present
versus future how to find an equilibrium
in a bunch of people with different
desires all that sort of good stuff so
let's go
[Music]
thank you
Amy Finkelstein welcome to the mindscape
podcast thanks a lot for having me Sean
I'm delighted to be here I wanted to
mention right at the start that in your
new book Risky Business a delightful
book happy to recommend to everybody uh
one of the delightful things about it is
right up at the front you are honest
you're candid and you you admit to your
audience that insurance markets might
not seem like the sexiest topic to to
read or write a book about so I thought
I would at least just open just in case
someone listens to the podcast for just
five minutes give us your sales pitch
for why Insurance markets are sexier
than people might think well that's a
pretty low bar I'll actually go for
their sexy on an absolute scale
uh oh you know we all have our our
different tastes um so the reason I
think insurance is so exciting and the
reason I've spent most of my career
studying it is that insurance offers the
possibility of doing something that I
think is is is quite magical it offers
the hope for a measure of security and
certainty in a dangerous and uncertain
World Insurance touches nearly every
aspect of Our Lives we ensure our cars
our houses our pets and literally our
lives and when you think about all the
risks we face in the world from disease
to death to natural disasters you know
there's this tantalizing prospect that
we can eliminate some of not all but
some of the vicissitudes and vagaries
that plague our lives so that's that's
why I think it's exciting you know that
it's you know the tantalizing what
economists call free lunch right
everyone everyone can benefit uh but
what our book is about is the fact that
despite I think this very real and and
potentially valuable service Insurance
often fails to deliver on its promise
and few people understand why and the
results of that lack of understanding as
we describe in the book can be you know
ruined businesses ruined policies and
ruined lives and so our hope in writing
this book is to help people understand
uh some of the ostensibly frustrating
features of many Insurance markets why
dental insurance is so crummy why pet
insurance is so expensive why if you've
tried you'll have discovered you can't
buy divorce insurance For Love or Money
um and also why there's a real
possibility for for the government to
step in and try and improve uh Insurance
markets but why that's hard also and how
it sometimes fails as well well that
that's you you touched on the reason why
as a as a physicist philosopher I did uh
I was I was a soft target for your
introduction because insurance does you
know when you get right down to it the
nitty-gritty of personal finance I'm I'm
terrible at and I have no interest in
getting better at it but there are these
big picture questions about sort of
trading present value for future
certainty you know a bargain between
your present self and your and your
future self is sort of intellectually a
fascinating notion to pursue
yeah I mean and I think you know
economists tend to think and there's a
lot of evidence that most people are
what we call risk averse that they're
willing to give up a small amount of
money for certainty for certain to avoid
the perhaps small possibility of a much
much larger loss so we'd rather pay you
know a few a hundred dollars a year in
premiums then you know and then in the
unfortunate event that say our car is
totaled we then get the money to you
know repair the car or or buy a new car
and Not only would we prefer to do that
but it's not irrational to do that right
I actually did recently a podcast with
the philosopher Lara buchaku studies
risk and rationality and she makes the
case that even if you're
it's she she sort of she she frames it
as taunting economists a little bit
because there's something we do in our
rational decision making other than
maximizing our average expected utility
sometimes we are willing to forego a
little bit of utility if we can lower
our volatility the lower our risk a
little bit
yeah so I I would say though um there
are many things to taunt economists
about but that isn't one of them I think
that that's actually Central to
economics it's the idea going back to
Von Neumann and Morgenstern of
maximizing expected utility so you know
you would be happier having you know say
you have a 10 chance you might lose a
hundred dollars right that means you
know on average you're only going to
lose ten dollars uh so you might be
willing to pay ten dollars for sure and
then you know uh 90 times out of a
hundred you're you know actually not
going to lose any money and you just
paid you you get your ninety dollars but
the you know one time you do you you get
you also get your ninety dollars so you
you never risk losing the whole hundred
dollars in fact maybe you'd even be
willing to pay like 11 bucks for that I
think I think that's that's irrational
that's that's you know that's the bread
and butter of a lot of Economics no well
that's right but that paying eleven
dollars in that case that you just
raised is lowering your expected utility
but it's still rational right
no it's raising your expected utility
because you're giving up you're 11.
you're gonna have you're gonna have 89
for sure both periods you know say or
you have 89 for sure rather than facing
you know one you know a 90 probability
of having a hundred dollars and a 10
probability of having zero dollars and
you may be happier with that there's
nothing irrational about it of course X
post if you don't if you don't
experience the loss You'll wish you
haven't paid the premium but you know
that that's a that's not what insurance
is about well actually yeah that's
another good point you make in the
beginning is that part of the utility
you get from paying insurance is the
peace of mind right that you're covered
a little bit and that has to be factored
in for sure for sure I was also
surprised to learn uh you know how deep
into the past it goes and I recently
wrote a book that had an anecdote in it
about Edmund Halley the comment guy and
so did you so tell Eddie had no idea
that Ali had anything to do with
insurance
no neither neither did uh we until or
neither did I at least I can't speak for
my co-authors until we started uh
writing this book and you know you
mentioned uh uh that you're a physicist
uh uh and you know my understanding is
that you know physicists like to make
fun of economists and mathematicians
like to make fun of physicists and
that's kind of the you know intellectual
pecking order so from that perspective
that I've you know lived with my whole
life
um it was fun for us uh to discover that
you know uh Edmund uh Holly uh the
comment guy as you said and also in the
distinguished 17th century mathematician
Abraham de mavra uh were both involved
in coming up with Actuarial tables
calculating mortality risk rates for you
know or death rates calculations and
using those to price uh survival
Insurance something known as annuities
and while they may be and I think were
excellent scientists they were not very
good social scientists so sometimes
order doesn't hold in the sense that
they calculated the mortality tables
correctly for the population that they
had data for
um but what they weren't thinking of is
the fact that the once you start selling
these survival contingent streams of
payment these things called annuities
which the actually the the French and
Dutch governments were doing in the 17th
century to finance War as much the way
modern governments issue bonds or
treasury bills so they'd say you know to
perspective to speculators you know you
give me a bunch of money and we'll pay
you every year until someone that you've
nominated dies so what they did what
what Haley and demovra didn't realize is
that you know the set of people who's on
whom those bets are placed are not
randomly drawn from the population right
so for example in the French case they
looked for you know young French girls
who had already survived smallpox so
those people had you know quite a much
longer survival prospects than say older
men and then you know after a couple
hundred years and and arguably the
French Revolution because this did
bankrupt uh Louis XIV these these
mispriced annuities uh you know
eventually people caught on and thought
okay well we'll you know we'll we'll say
We'll price the annuities differently if
you're taking them out a bet on the
survival of a 70 year old male as
opposed to a five-year-old girl but even
then you know it turned out that you
know speculators found the the really
really hell and Hearty old men in
Scotland and placed bets on them and
even in modern times we continue to see
these types of issues coming up you know
this is an aside but let me just get on
the record that I think that the pecking
order that he referred to as essentially
never true whenever I see people in
highly technical Fields think that other
fields are easier when you see them try
to do it they're not really very good at
it there's a whole other set of skills
that are required and we should all
recognize that uh but poor Hallie he did
okay in other areas he got the comment
named after him so that's okay and to
your point I'm sure I would never have
discovered that comment that comment
sorry that I would never have discovered
that comment even if I might have you
know with the benefit of a few hundred
more years of Economics figured out the
selection problem but his yeah his
mistake that that you're pointing to is
sort of the center of of what we have to
talk about here because uh well you're
the World's expert I should let you uh
describe what's going on here but
there's a thing called adverse selection
there's a thing in Insurance unlike
selling cars or smartphones where you
care about who is buying it you do not
get the same value for any different
kind of buyer
exactly in fact you've made the announce
you made the comparison which is
perfectly accurate to you know a
smartphone or a car you know the the
comparison we love um is one of the
things that prompted us to write this
book which was uh listening to the
Supreme Court uh oral arguments over
whether or not the mandate to require
everyone to buy health insurance under
Obamacare was constitutional now we have
nothing to say on constitutional law but
what what what intrigued us was hearing
then Supreme Court Justice Antonin
Scalia asked during oral arguments well
if the government can force people to
buy health insurance can it also force
them to eat their broccoli now he was
obviously being rhetorical and trying to
conjure up you know this image of a
undesirable intrusive state but I think
to to many people if not to Scalia the
distinction at least the distinction
we're interested in between insurance
and broccoli is not clear and the reason
it might make sense you know we jokingly
thought of calling our book you know why
is Insurance different than broccoli but
we thought putting two unpopular things
in the title was probably not a good
idea but but the reason we think there
may be a role for the government in
mandating that people buy insurance be
it auto insurance flood insurance health
insurance but not for eating their
broccoli uh is precisely what you said
when uh when when the supermarket sells
its broccoli the profits and the
profitability of that broccoli depend
only on the price it charges and how
many customers buy it it does not depend
on which customers buy it that is not
true for insurance uh how much it costs
an insurer to ensure uh automobiles or
or houses or lives depends on whether
the customers who buy it are high risk
accident-prone customers or low-risk
ones and once you realize that you what
what one will realize or economic
theorists in the 1970s going back to
Georgia akerloff realized is that this
can wreak havoc on the market that if
you offer an insurance product the
people who are going to flock to it are
the people who know that they're riskier
uh higher expected costs than the
typical buyers happen to you know admin
Halley in the in the you know hundreds
of years ago and it and it happens today
we give examples in the book with
divorce insurance and layoff insurance
that uh entrepreneurs tried to offer
these products and they found very
quickly that the customers that were
buying them were not the customers they
wanted so they had to raise the price to
you know to cover the higher than
expected rates of divorce among people
who had divorce insurance or rates of uh
layoff among people buying layoff
Insurance well unfortunately what
raising the price does it sounds like a
sensible solution to my costs are higher
than my revenues that might be you know
business school lesson 101 the problem
is selection market like an insurance
market is when you raise your price you
just exacerbate the selection problem
now it's only the really really high
risk the ones who like you know already
are bickering with their spouse or you
know have have already seen the pink
slip who are going to buy this you know
uh protection and the market and we give
examples in the book can just literally
uh spiral out of control and have what's
called a death spiral it can completely
disappear and so going back to why
insurance is both exciting but also
important to understand I started by
saying it's exciting because it offers a
measure of security but this type of
selection problem can destroy that
potential and that's a problem not just
for the people who already know they're
about to get laid off or about to get
divorced but for all of us because we
all I think value having some Security
even though I believe I'm happily
married and at no risk of divorce or
very low risk and likewise you know have
secure employment it's still would be
great to know that in the unfortunate
event that I lose my job or my you know
marriage that that I had some Financial
Resources to help cover the costs of
those events so everyone can benefit
from insurance the low risk and the high
risk the problem is that selection can
make it impossible for either everyone
or most people to benefit from that
insurance and as it is intellectually
interesting to someone like me because
it is an example of a market failure and
I know that economists are well aware
that markets do fail like that is that
is a bad stereotype to think that
economists think that markets never fail
but they're sort of standard ways in
which markets can fail either by you
know exacerbating inequality or by
monopolies or things like that and this
is kind of a a different way there's
nothing
nothing you know uh mistaken about it
everyone is doing the individually
rational thing but the market is just
driving you to an equilibrium that no
one wants to be in yes and that's what
is so to me so fascinating about it is
that you could have a situation in which
everyone values Insurance they're
actually willing to pay a price that's
actually Fair based on their own risk
which means they're willing to go to go
back to our example of the 10 chance of
losing a hundred dollars right the the
Actuarial cost the expected cost to the
insurance company is ten dollars and I
might be willing to pay eleven dollars
to avoid that risk and so even if
everyone were willing to do that so that
everyone gets gains from buying from
buying insurance at a price that allows
the insurance company to break even or
even make a tiny bit of money and yet
that market may not exist that's what's
so you know both frustrating and
intriguing about insurance markets yeah
and it's worth emphasizing you said it
several times but I just want to
emphasize it uh just so that no one
misses it that the idea of insurance by
itself is not a scam it is you know it
is true that the insurance companies
going to make money that if everything
goes well you will be spending more
money than you get back on average but
it's worth it because of this uh lower
risk higher certainty the peace of mind
you get along the way
yes to most people I mean there are some
people you know the the skydivers and
bungee jumpers Among Us who may love
risk and not but but I think you know so
I'm not saying that it's irrational for
everyone to not buy insurance at a at a
fair price but most people value it and
yes this is what you know this is how
markets work when when I you know value
the car more than it costs Volkswagen to
make it then that's what we call gains
from trade and you know we can argue
about how to split the Surplus you know
should they make no profits a tiny bit
of lot you know but but that's that's a
good thing that's the economy
functioning and what's what's amazing
about insurance markets is there can be
that that Surplus on the table and yet
the market doesn't function or you know
for people who you know insurers I think
have a bit of a bad rap and and for
sometimes with reason you know one of
the things is that you know listeners
may think oh come on but insurance is
priced exorbitantly it's not it's not
just priced you know in my example like
oh I haven't expected loss of of ten
dollars you know this one in ten chance
of losing a hundred dollars and so fine
maybe I'd be willing to pay eleven
dollars they're charging me they're
charging a price of fifty dollars right
yes and that is empirically correct so
if we talk in the book for example if
you look at the market for pet health
insurance which has been growing over
the last couple decades the price is
really are exorbitant relative to the
risk so for example a 12 year old
bulldog if you want to insure him the
annual premium is four thousand three
hundred dollars and here's the kicker
the maximum payout is five thousand
dollars so that that is a very very high
price but one of the reasons the price
is so high is because the people who are
insuring their 12 year old Bulldogs are
the people who know not only that Rover
you know is gonna about to need a lot of
medical care but that they're the type
of owner who if Rover does need that
medical care are not going to you know
give him some pain relief and sadly say
goodbye they're going to you know do the
high-tech invasive surgery on their 12
year old dog and so one of the reasons
Insurance uh looks so bad and gets such
a bad rap is because it often is high
priced and also Limited in all kinds of
annoying ways you know with waiting
periods and deductibles but that's there
precisely because of the selection
problem it's the insurers trying to
figure out how they can you know ensure
this risk that is so adversely selected
yeah and the example of pet insurance
prefigures something I want to get to
later but it's not just pets we have
this difference of strategy about it's
ourselves right you know the topic of
insurance brings up injury and sickness
and death and a lot of bad things that
can happen to us and different Among Us
are willing to fight and fight to Stave
off death as long as possible and that
might affect how much we're willing to
pay for the medical care and therefore
the insurance totally and so the this
this selection thing about the spiral
where you only get the uh the the worst
customers who want to pay for your
um product that it has a crucially
interesting connection to the
information that different people have
right it's an example where the people
who want to buy your insurance know
they're in trouble they know they're
going to get divorced and therefore
they're buying it and presumably the
insurance company doesn't know that
yes and and you've hit on I think one of
the one of the really
um
puzzling aspects of this whole problem
that we spend some time grappling with
in the book which is how can it be that
you know you have on the one hand these
massive insurers who face major you know
Financial incentives to figure out just
how risky their customers are and price
it accordingly they have you know mounds
of data they have you know sophisticated
uh actuaries and act you know Actuarial
scientists and their data algorithms you
know in the world of Big Data today how
is it possible that you know there are
things that people know about themselves
that the insurance company uh doesn't
know so we talk about this in the book
we give
um some anecdotes which I'm happy to
share to illustrate we also provide some
of the empirical evidence in some case
uh clever researchers have been able to
document uh specific forms of this
private information such as you know uh
knowing for example whether you know if
you have a parent with the genetic
disease for Huntington's Korea there's
evidence so you have a 50 50 chance of
having it yourself it's a dominant gene
there's evidence that people at risk for
Huntington's Korea have much higher
rates of purchasing nursing home
insurance than people who don't have
that Gene the risk of the Gene and then
even among the people at risk once they
do the genetic tests the people who test
positive tend to buy the insurance at
higher rates the people who don't test
so in some cases we've been able to
pinpoint the source of it in other cases
it's it's genuinely surprising in the
case of life insurance for example an
economist named Dai fingha has
documented that if you look at people
who look the same on every possible
dimension of their health and their
family history that you can think of and
you look at who buys life insurance and
who doesn't and then follow them
prospectively over time the people who
by life insurance are more likely to die
in the next 10 years
and so we don't you know when we try to
think what is it that the life in
insurer isn't you know figuring out well
do they not know your you know your
health no they actually come into a
medical exam do they not know your
family medical history nope they ask
about that maybe it's your lifestyle
choices don't they ask about your
smoking and your skydiving and whether
you travel to dangerous places so there
are cases where we don't know what it is
but the data are very clear that's there
is something that people know above and
beyond what the insurance company is
able to figure out about them so so the
idea that you know oh in the world of
big data will somehow get rid of this
selection problem because big brother
will know everything about us uh turns
out not not quite everything
is there any chance that the causal flow
is that buying health insurance or life
insurance makes you die earlier
so this is
Central uh empirical challenges to
researchers in this area the problem
we've been talking about is one of
selection that people who um
that people who are higher risk are more
likely to buy the insurance in the first
place the the other possibility that you
refer to is known as moral hazard it's
the idea that even if uh identical
people there are a bunch of people who
all are the same risk and then we just
randomly give some of them automobile
insurance and other people not the
people who have the insurance will now
you know put their foot on the gas pedal
a little more and drive a little uh less
carefully
um in health insurance there's a there's
a huge body of evidence some of which
I've contributed to
documenting precisely this phenomenon
that once people get health insurance
including randomly assigned health
insurance we did a randomized evaluation
of this in the state of Oregon people
you know take a group of people and you
randomly give half of them insurance and
Medicaid and half of them remain on
insured so they're on average those two
groups are the same in terms of their
health their their propensity to use the
doctor but the ones who get insurance do
in fact then go to the doctor more so
moral hazard is alive and well but we
also know that there's uh selection and
one of the ways you can see this is
Imagine now uh you randomize not uh
whether you have insurance you but you
randomize this is other work we've done
effectively randomized the price at
which people are offered insurance so a
higher price or a low price lower price
one of the things you see in the data is
you can then look at the people who
choose to buy insurance at the higher
price and the lower price so everyone
has insurance so any effects of
insurance making me more likely to go to
the doctor that's the same what's
different between the two groups is one
consists of a group of people who are
willing to buy health insurance at a low
price the other consists of a group of
people who are willing to buy it not
only at a low price but also at a higher
price there's fewer of them right
because we know people don't like high
prices but you see the set of people who
are willing to buy when the price is
higher have much higher Health Care
utilization after the fact than the
people who bought when the health when
the price was lower so raising the price
gets you a risky set of of customers
again you're comparing two groups of
people both of whom have insurance so
that behavioral effect of the insurance
you know on your health care use is
operating for both of them but one the
group that was willing to buy at an even
higher price
it has even more Health Care use coming
from the fact that they they're only
willing to buy it because they expect it
to have higher use this is I mean you
are bringing up the fact that this is a
nice case where interests align arguably
right I mean the insurance company wants
you to be healthy and not use the doctor
a lot and so maybe their best interests
are served by encouraging you to adopt
healthy behaviors
this is this is a great segue to another
example we talk about in the book that
also gets into this is it about
selecting the customers or changing
their behavior yeah so something uh
something that we've observed many times
in the world perhaps some of listeners
have actually experienced this is it
some health insurance companies will
offer discounts for a gym membership
bundle that along with their health
insurance and you might think going back
to your you know oh incentives are
aligned points that that's because it's
great for the you know in health insurer
if you go to the gym and stay get
healthier just like it's good for you
too
but the data show that that's not what's
going on so there's fascinating work by
the researchers Cooper and trevetti who
show that uh if you if when insurers
start offering these discounted gym
memberships bundled with the health
insurance product they attract customers
who are already healthier you can
measure their health before they buy the
insurance
moreover there's other excellent work
done by three economists Daemon Jones
David Molitor and Julian reiff in which
they actually ran a randomized
controlled trial of offering employees a
workness wellness program at their
University at the University of Illinois
at Urbana-Champaign and what they found
by comparing you know people offered the
workplace wellness program and people
who weren't is it didn't make you any
healthier didn't make you any more
productive all the things that you know
uh uh you know employ employers or
workplace Wellness aficionados will tout
but they also found that there's a
reason that employers still offer it
which is the types of employees who like
to sign up for workplace Wellness
programs are healthier at Baseline right
it's the same reason that uh Cooper and
trevetti find that Health insurers offer
gym memberships it's the peop because
they want to attract the healthy
customers at least the the relatively
more healthy and fit Among Us can at
least delude ourselves into thinking
we're really going to use that gym
membership uh but it turns out it
doesn't actually make you healthier it
just gets you healthier customers right
so even if I'm not the kind of person
who literally goes to the gym by the
fact that I would want to be a member of
the gym this I'm talking about friends
of mine not myself but that's a hint
that correlates with other healthy
behaviors and so I want those people in
mind exactly exactly this is very
complicated this is why physicists would
not be very good at it physicists are
much better it's simple things and
there's a lot of a lot of confounding
variables coming in here but let me back
up again to you know once again sort of
understand what's going on with the idea
of insurance and how it feeds into the
the aspects of it we just mentioned the
idea is to spread risk right I mean when
you when you buy the insurance
presumably you're not buying it from
your friend you're buying it from a much
larger company who can live through the
flex situations up and down
exactly exactly again the the idea is
you take you know a hundred people or a
million people each of whom has you know
a one in ten chance of losing that
hundred dollars and you spread that risk
around only on at you know the law of
large numbers will work on average you
know yeah one in ten of us will lose
that hundred dollars but if we all pull
together then you know not all of us
will lose it and if we all give a little
bit of money that can cover the losses
for the few the one in ten who do lose
it so it's exactly this sort of uh
collect you know sort of um making it a
communal smoothing the risk or spreading
the risk as you nicely said across the
community am I misremembering or was I
misinformed that there were companies in
you know the stock market crashes or
financial crisis that had insured
themselves which is sort of almost a
contradiction in terms
okay yes so there is something called
reinsurance which which is is somewhat
bizarre at first glance and maybe even
at Second Glance which is insurers in
turn reinsure their risk and sometimes
the reasons are because you know there
is some risk of a correlated shock so
the example I gave with you know the the
10 chance of losing a hundred dollars
where it's just you know totally uh each
person has a one in ten you know
10-sided coin flip chance since I had a
die roll what have you in that case it's
going to be very unlikely with a large
enough pool that say everyone gets wiped
out
but on the other hand if you're saying
insurer who's insuring uh against
Natural Disasters yeah
Etc and you're you're sort of
geographically concentrated in say
Florida or California some years you may
have no costs in some years you may have
you know 80 of your customers have claim
and so you then in some sense you may
want to lay off some of that risk to a
larger pool that's more Diversified
across either other types of insurance
or geographically or has a larger
Capital stock and can bear that risk and
so it's clear why as the seller of
insurance as the insurance company we
really do want to have a good
statistical grasp on what the pool is
that we're selling to what the risks are
Etc I mean how much like super fancy
math goes into that is there a lot of
power laws and long tails uh and and
heavy duty statistical techniques here
or is it more or less just don't make
the mistakes that have been Halle make
and you'll be fine
I think you know for for right lot right
tail low probability right tail events
this came up a lot you know with
terrorism insurance after 9 11.
UM you know there's also the sort of
weird with some of these things where
there's uncertainty about the risk you
know there's we know a lot about
mortality risk we know a lot less about
say terrorism risk and therefore if an
event occurs you up you know you have
you you as the insurer or the public
would update your probabilities of a
future event occurring so so some of
that Actuarial science can some of it's
quite straightforward and you know the
pricing you know mortality tables at
this point we've been doing for a while
some is much more complicated but all of
it then it's not enough to get the
Actuarial science right you then have to
think about who's going to be buying
that product and how might they differ
from the typical population on which you
know you've calculated those
probabilities
so clearly the as I said the um
insurance companies want to gonna want
to know its customers as well as it can
and you already mentioned this or
alluded to this but are there any
circumstances in which the insurance
companies know more than their customers
about their customers own risks
that's a really great question I think
it I think when it comes I don't I don't
know for sure but I've we've thought
about this a lot and the way we think
about it is
it's not a like less versus more thing
than at some level of course you know a
a life science actuary is going to have
a much you know uh more precise
prediction of my mortality than I am I
mean just even if I you know looking up
a life table for someone of my age and
gender and maybe a few other
characteristics would probably do better
than I could do off the top of my head
so in that sense you could say yeah the
insurance company or the actuary quote
unquote knows more on the other hand the
way my informational Advantage comes in
is whatever the insurer knows they use
to offer the insurance and they say okay
here's the price at which I'm going to
offer Insurance to you know middle-aged
female economists you know with a great
sense of humor and and two bratty kids
or what have you right and then and then
but then I and so I would not have known
how to price that but then once they
give me the price I know that among that
group of you know middle-aged uh female
economists with great senses of humor I
know something about whether I'm more or
less risky than the typical so that's
that's where my informational Advantage
comes in it's not like if we had a
competition of who could you know get
get the Actuarial tables right that I do
better than they would
um it is like what they kind of move
first and then I get to react yeah okay
good and so I mean maybe we should think
about the obligations of the person to
reveal some of these things right or
maybe the obligations that go both ways
um my understanding is that if the
insurance company asks you about your
medical status you have to be honest
with them you can't lie but you don't
need to volunteer things that they don't
ask you is that roughly the idea
that's correct and just to be clear
um you you could lie I wouldn't advise
it because right it's very expensive to
verify all this information and so I my
my understanding is for example with
life insurance they don't from well they
do do a medical exam but for many things
they will take your self-reported word
for it but then if you actually have a
claim then they'll investigate and so
it's a very very bad idea to try and
shade the truth because you'll end up
paying all these premiums and then if in
the event that you actually need the
insurance then you could be denied
um but yeah I think you know
I I guess you know even if you yeah yeah
I don't know why you would have I mean
as an ethical matter I don't know why
it's my responsibility to to tell
someone you know more about my risk than
they ask I need to be truthful uh things
one of you know but again and it's as
you were talking about earlier it's
privately rational for us all to do that
it just messes things up in aggregate so
one of the examples we give in the book
you know is with auto insurance now you
know the saying is you know ninety
percent of people think they're above
average drivers well I'm one of the ten
percent who know I'm a below average
driver
um but when I uh first got a car which
was in my late 20s in graduate school
and I needed uh to get automobile
insurance I didn't think it was my job
to tell them that I answered all their
questions truthfully they asked a bunch
of questions like you know the make and
model of my you know car and then they
asked how long I'd had my license and
whether I you know had any you know
accidents or speeding tickets and the
the truthful answer was that I had had
my license for 10 years and I had an
absolutely spotless driving record
so what the insurance company didn't
know that I knew and anyone who spent
any time in a car with me would quickly
learn is that I'm a terrible driver and
the reason I had a spotless driving
record is because I never drove right so
I've gotten my license uh as a 17 year
old growing up in Manhattan because my
mom told me I really should get it it
would be useful to have the ID on the
driver's license I got the license and I
never drove so I answered every question
truthfully they just you know that it
was just something about me that was
kind of idiosyncratic that they didn't
know yes but they do know that you live
in Massachusetts so I bet that they
assume that you're below average driver
just on the basis of that data exactly
but I knew I was a below average driver
even among Massachusetts drivers and
that's exactly my point they probably
knew much better than me with the
empirical rate of accidents are in
Massachusetts but I knew mine would be
higher and speaking of the ethical
obligations so those are the other the
obligations of the insured for the
insurer
uh how much are they allowed to just
discriminate to just say well look I
know that you're a very very risky group
so your premiums are much higher that
that's good business sense how legal is
it
so that's a really good question again
with the caveat that I am not a legal
expert our understanding and we talk
about this in the book is that what
insurers are allowed to price on varies
a lot both state to state and also
Insurance to Insurance uh some insurance
you know are more heavily regulated than
others the thing that we talk about a
lot in the book is you know not the
legal matters but the uh and not even
really the ethical models here though we
try and talk about that a bit but more
just from an economic perspective what
are the consequences of saying no you
can't price uh health insurance on the
basis of pre-existing conditions right
so let's take that as an example now on
the one hand we totally understand where
this comes from that it seems
unjust or unfair that people who are
unfortunate enough to have some chronic
health condition uh that in addition
they have to pay more for their health
insurance
on the other hand what we what we have
seen happen and we talk about this as
well in the book is that when States
come in and so for example New York and
New Jersey did this in the 1990s and in
the Private health insurance markets the
ones that aren't through your employer
they said it's not they said basically
yeah we we don't think it's fair and you
can't price health insurance differently
for People based on their pre-existing
conditions you actually can't charge
higher prices based on anything you have
to offer the same price it's called a
community rate to everyone in the
community and you have to you know they
it's so-called guaranteed issue you also
have to sell to everyone who who wants
the insurance you can't say well here's
the price but only only for you Sean and
not for UAB we don't have insurance for
you well this guaranteed issue is
guaranteed to create issues and what we
saw happen there is exactly what you'd
expect if everyone has to be charged the
same price and and offered Insurance
then on average the people who buy the
insurance or the older
individuals that drives up the price
that of that insurance because insurance
companies have to be getting in enough
to cover their claims that drives the
healthiest of those older sicker
individuals out of the market and drive
risk up more and the price up more and
in the case of New York and New Jersey
it drove the market completely out of
existence wow
um so so yes it was fairer no one was
being treated differently but everyone
was in the same poor situation of having
no access to this health insurance
product now because economists always
love you know on the one hand on the
other hand let me let me also give you
the other hand which is
if
but it sounds if you're trying to deal
with problems of private information and
selection from a pure economics point of
view it can sound nutty to say we're
going to restrict what the insurance
company can use in pricing that's like
creating private information for the
customer on the other hand if what you
want is not insurance for my claims this
year given that I'm a you know
relatively unhealthy individual but I
want insurance against being an
unhealthy individual right sort of
behind the roles invale of ignorance
then it makes perfect sense to have
Community rating uh charge everyone the
same because it that's to reflect the
fact that if we charge higher premiums
to people who are higher cost to people
who are worse drivers or less healthy
then we lose the insurance or the
potential for insurance against the
possibility of being unlucky enough such
as myself to have been born a terrible
driver or someone who's born with a
genetic disease or predisposition to
certain chronic conditions and that's
one of the reasons you can think that
the government may get involved to say
look
we don't know how to or I'm not a
philosopher but I don't think we know
how to literally buy insurance behind
the veil of ignorance you know in utero
as it were but but that's actually a
role that the government can play
good so that's the perfect place to get
into that so just to summarize we could
imagine letting the insurers use all the
information they have and discriminate
as much as they want but that seems a
little unfair the people who need the
insurance products the most are being
charged or the least able to afford it
are being charged the most so we could
try to make it fair by insisting that
everyone be charged the same but then we
have the selection effect where only the
riskiest people are buying it so the
next obvious twist to put on it is to
say now everyone has to buy insurance
right
correct so rather than just require that
the insurers offer it to everyone at the
same price right which gets you your
guaranteed issues you can uh instead
also insist that everyone buy it at that
price so whether that's you know the
government providing it directly or as
in the case of automobile insurance and
and most recently health insurance
mandating that everyone provided and
that's why going back to the Scalia
question about can you force everyone to
eat their broccoli if you could force
them to buy health insurance those are
two very different situations but one
thing I learned or or relearned I should
say from watching the experience of the
health insurance mandates play out is
both that the economic theory really
does apply in practice but also perhaps
not surprisingly it is true that the
real world is more complicated than
what's dreamed of in our philosophy and
so what we saw so I think two main
lessons came out of of thinking about
these mandates so the first is you know
the textbook model is that mandates are
a way to solve the selection problem
because if everyone has to have
insurance then by definition there's no
selection everyone's in you've got your
random or representative pool what I
hadn't really thought about until that
we I watched this play out in practice
is again to use the broccoli analogy
anyone who has you know young children
knows that saying You must eat your
broccoli to your toddler doesn't make it
so and similarly saying that people must
have health insurance mandating it also
it turns out doesn't make it show so and
what turns out to matter a lot and
there's evidence of this from from
Massachusetts is what kinds of penalties
are put in place for people who don't
buy insurance and when those penalties
are in place you see that that's much
more effective at getting the healthy
customers into the market than simply
saying You must buy insurance uh so you
know there's the old Robin Williams joke
out the the cops in in England who the
bodies as they're called who don't they
don't carry guns and so he dead pans
well what do they do when they're
arresting a criminal they yell they
shout stop or I'll say stop again right
you know like it's not that effective
and similarly saying You must have
health insurance without putting some
teeth behind that is similarly not as
effective so again it's not just enough
to to mandate it you have to enforce the
Mandate uh which which may sound obvious
but to get quickly back to the types of
issues that uh you know we were saying
what's what is and isn't what it is or
isn't fair
um one way to enforce a mandate is to
find people for not complying the other
way instead of the stick is the carrot
it's to subsidize people for complying
and that's a lot of what we've done
effectively under the Affordable Care
Act is especially for lower income
individuals offer subsidies for people
to buy health insurance
one of the things economists have
pointed out which is true but also you
can see why it would be unpopular is if
you're trying to design those selections
excuse me if you're trying to design
those subsidies to deal with the
selection problem
the people that you should be
subsidizing are the people who in some
sense you feel like might need the
subsidies the least right it's not the
old sick people you want to subsidize
the young healthy people that's actually
how you'd solve the selection problem
not clear that's going to fly you know
past the sniff test with Joe public
well so public does get in the way a lot
but Joe public also you know there's
there's a folk wisdom there I mean one
of the off-putting aspects of the
Affordable Care Act even though I
thought it was a great step forward
myself was oh my goodness there were a
lot of complications and bureaucracy and
paperwork and that that is both
intrinsically off-putting but it also
just opens up new venues for malfeasance
right I mean you mentioned in the book
about what a huge amount is spent on
lobbying the government by insurance
companies and people in that sector and
and this is part of the reason why right
when there's a lot of rules there are a
lot of loopholes
absolutely absolutely
um this is another thing we talk about
in the book that because sometimes the
selection problem when the government
gets in and tries to fix things the
selection problem can cease being a game
between the customer and the insurer and
can become a game between the government
and the insurer in which and then the
government is often on the losing side
yes so right again imagine so one
example and that we discuss in the book
is
um the uh public Medicare program which
provides uh health insurance the
individual 65 and over uh automatically
through the tax system there's an option
instead that was created in the 80s and
has become much bigger in recent decades
to try to allow people more choice in
the type of health insurance they have
and to also allow the private Market to
maybe reap some of the potential its
potential efficiencies which is you can
let private insurers offer Medicare and
people may prefer the product that
they're offering it has to meet some
minimum requirements that the regular
Medicare program but then they can also
provide additional benefits and some
people really and then the idea is that
the government instead of paying for
your uh Medicare pays the private
insurer to insure you instead so in
other words you know rather than the
government bearing all of our medical
costs it sells some of our risk to a
private company who thinks they can
manage your risk better right so that
sounds perfectly fine until then you
have to think about well you know how
much should uh should the government pay
a private insurer to take a Medicare
customer off its hands if the customer
wants to go to that insurer and what the
government would like to do is is pay
them you know what they would have spent
to cover this person with Medicare or
maybe even a little less if the
government wants to save money okay so
it sets a price it says look older
people are more expensive uh maybe women
are more expensive than men and then
guess what that the Private health
insurer is going to want to uh fight the
healthiest people by age and gender and
they may do it by off in fact they do it
by offering things like gym memberships
and other strategies like that and so
then the government you know we talk
about this in the game we talk about it
sort of a game of whack-a-mole well the
government got smart to that and started
collecting data on your past medical
claims because that's you know it's one
thing that's gonna you know going to
predict your future matter claims is
your past one if I've been to the doctor
in hospital a lot over the last year I'm
likely to be high cost this coming year
so they start pricing then on additional
things and that can you know help solve
the pro help with the problem but it
doesn't it doesn't solve it entirely and
and you know round and round you go with
the insurer always kind of staying one
one step ahead of the government right
whenever the government does the insurer
then spends some time trying to think
about you know how it can
grandma says we say cream scam the best
customers
do other countries have to put up with
all this is we've been talking about the
United States we both lived there but we
have international listeners here on
mindscape is this just a global
phenomenon that is a result of the
structure of insurance and markets or is
is the United States a special outlier
election is a global problem that's a
function of markets and not only
Insurance markets although it's one of
the biggest examples and we try and
convince our readers one of the more
interesting ones you know selection
markets can occur whenever uh the the
different customers are going to impose
different costs on the seller and the
customer knows something that the seller
doesn't so we give examples in the book
of saying all you can eat restaurant
um or um in or Education Loans that
people have uh
universities have tried to offer in
which their so-called income sharing
agreements in which the amount you have
to pay back depends on how much you make
after college and what you see and the
economists Nathan hendren and Daniel
Herbst have shown this very nicely is
that even when you look at what college
people are going to and what their major
is people still have private information
about how much they're going to make
after college and guess who wants to buy
the income sharing agreement the ones
who aren't going to make very much so
it's a pervasive problem that's not
about the country or even the particular
Market that being said although this is
probably uh more a topic for a different
podcast it's also the subject of our
next book in the particulars of health
insurance the way the United States has
tried to deal with this problem is
unique and we have come to conclude
uniquely problematic relative to how
other high income countries have have
tried to deal with this yeah that's the
type of for other podcasts but an
extremely believable claim given our uh
empirical information but but with all
that in mind that we've been exploring
here is there this is probably an unfair
question is there a simple set of things
that we should obviously be doing better
here in the United States for the world
than we are doing
we being the government for the society
I'm sorry Society the whole the totality
the system so I would say for society no
I think one of the messages of our book
which may make it you know not a popular
sound bite on late night TV but is an
important message is
there these there aren't facile
Solutions there there really are
trade-offs um take even uh the case of
mandates that we've talked about already
and think about
um perfect enforcement of the Mandate so
we don't have to deal with that issue
there's still the question of what you
know how much Insurance should the
government mandate and you see for
example an automobile insurance the the
minimum requirements are are very
drastically across States now if you
mandate a very very low amount of
insurance coverage and most people want
more than that you're just kind of
recreating the selection problem but now
it's on the margin of how much Insurance
you buy rather than whether you buy it
at all
um on the other hand if you uh set very
high minimum requirements as some states
do then you have the problem that maybe
not everyone actually wants that amount
of insurance right so so it really these
are not uh these are not
um issues that sort of are straight
forward another example that I think is
is kind of an interesting and important
one is you know the problem with
selection or and with insurance markets
is that um
people don't have choice of the products
that we think they should have that
should have available to them and yet
one of the ways we deal with that
problem is to try to restrict people's
choices so we give the example in the
book there was a sort of scathing New
York Times expose that got our blood
boiling where it talked about a very
unfortunate case of a man who um when he
was 65 and you know getting onto
MediCare at first you know was quite
healthy and therefore was attracted to
those gym memberships and the private
plans and got one and then unfortunately
about seven years later got quite ill
and wanted access to additional
Physicians and other things it has
planned to cover and tried to buy a you
know go back to the regular public
Medicare program and buy a supplemental
private policy to cover some of the gaps
and the and he he couldn't like no one
would sell him one and the the reason
was is because when you're 65 the
regular Nation says that you know again
you have to offer these plans to
everyone but the insurer but then after
the afterwards you don't and that's a
way of trying to not make the market
collapse have they always guaranteed
issue like New York and New Jersey had
but also
um you know prevent rampant selection
and so yes it was very unfortunate that
when he was sick he could not you know
get a more comprehensive policy but that
that's also how you prevent selection
from wreaking havoc on a market if you
let people wait till the risk occurs to
buy the insurance then you can destroy
the market for everyone
is there some argument that the that the
government should just give a basic
insurance plan to every person
there is that's the subject of my next
book that's coming out this summer with
my co-author Lauren I know from this one
but spoiler alert the act the argument
it turns out really isn't about
selection as much as we went into it
thinking it would be because that's what
we think about it's it's a it's a topic
for a different day it's it okay very
different
I'm sorry we'll look for that book that
that it's a very interesting question to
think about
um so there's two more things to get to
before before we end
um one is we were just hinting at it
with the example you gave of the older
gentleman trying to get insurance we're
not very good as a society or maybe even
as a species in planning for our last
days right uh we don't want to die most
of us we're willing to
spend the money we have to do it I mean
there's I there seems to me as someone
who is not there yet but you know
eventually will be that we have a system
in the United States where there are
ways that all of your wealth disappears
when you get old and sick because you're
willing to spend as much as you can to
stay alive and hospitals and doctors and
insurers are willing to take it and we
haven't quite figured out how to deal
with that
yes I and without denying that that is a
real problem let me give you though a
Counterpoint which is some work I've
done uh also if we're on INF who's my
co-author on this book as well as some
other economists which is to try to look
into this concern that comes up a lot
that
um about all the health care spending
that occurs at the end of life so the
fact that you might have heard that's
often quoted is that a quarter of all
medical spending on the elderly occurs
in the last 12 months of life
and it turns out that is actually true
so the first thing whenever you know you
I hear something a lot I I it sounds you
know you know inflammatory I wonder if
it's true we've checked and that isn't a
true fact but the next thing is if we
ask you know well there's two reasons
for that one is because you you know you
spend more when you get sick and people
who are sick have higher or death rates
they're more likely to die the other is
you know and that's that just seems
plausible like of course we spend money
more help more Healthcare money on sick
people than healthy people but if you
but but what's behind that the concern
about that fact is the is the
um assumption or sometimes assertion
that we're spending money on people who
we know are about to die right so
they're you know in intensive care
bedridden hooked up to many machines and
and clearly going to die it's only a
question a visit today or next week or
next month and we're spending all this
money to keep people alive for a few
more days and it turns out if you look
in the data and you use fairly
sophisticated machine learning
techniques and all their past health
records to predict their mortality it's
very very hard to know at the time
you're that most of this Medical Care is
occurring that people have a very very
high mortality so in other words even if
you look and we did this among people
who have been diagnosed with cancer and
are at a fairly late stage of cancer
right even you look at 80 year olds with
with cancer there's not many of them who
at the time they're getting their
medical treatment have you know a 70
percent plus annual mortality rate so
it's just it's very very hard to
identify a group of people that were
spending a lot of money on who are
actually you know going to die with 90
95 probability so yes death
probabilities are elevated among the
sick and yes we spend a lot lot of money
on the set but we're not spending money
on people that we a large group of
people who we quote unquote know with
high probability are going to die and
the example I always think of in trying
to explain this which you know obviously
is a little silly but I think kind of
drives home the point is um you know
when my uh when my kids go to were
learning to ski and they went to ski
school one of the things the ski
instructor always would say is you know
you really need to be careful towards
you know because uh most ski accidents
occur on the last run of the day to
which I thought well of course they do
because once you have an accident you
stop skiing right so again you know it
doesn't mean that like your probability
of a ski accident is necessarily higher
at four o'clock yeah
well oh no that's actually very very
helpful
data or information I mean it's it's
visually or viscerally I suppose I
should say a very different idea to
think that someone has a 95 mortality
rate and we're spending millions of
dollars versus someone even with a 50
mortality rate like if you say 50 50.
High rate but that's not dying for sure
I'm gonna keep fighting if I have 50 50
odds right yeah that's that's a for sure
especially if I could maybe live for
another 10 years that's that's an
enormous amount of time okay these
problems are hard again I really should
go into physics instead physics is so
much easier and unless less emotionally
taxing but speaking of physics or in the
very broadest sense the other question I
would bring up before we go is you've
alluded a couple of times to asking
these questions which are not only
intellectually interesting but morally
and politically charged and collecting
data to see what the answers are because
the answers aren't always what we might
guess or what our theories would predict
and apparently this is not all always uh
the way that people reach their
conclusions you've given talks you've
written about the need for more
empirical testing and the the difficulty
of empirical studies within economics
yes I think you know
um
one way to think about it is uh we all
have our hypotheses our prior beliefs
sometimes even our hope as to what you
know would be the effect of a policy but
it's incredibly important when we're
doing academic research or when the
public is trying to find out what the
effect of a policy is from that research
that we take great care to make sure
that
um we are getting cause and effect and
not spurious correlation and so there
there's been a real
um Revolution I would say in in in
empirical work my colleague Josh angrist
who uh won the Nobel Prize a couple
years ago for some of this work refers
to it as The credibility revolution in
trying to make sure that we're isolating
causal effects and one of the most
valuable Tools in in the work I do which
is mostly in health economics for do
doing that something that to my other uh
colleagues who are also on the Nobel
Prize it can be hard on the ego
who won the Nobel Prize in development
economics for popularizing this approach
um
in in in in for uh policies designed to
uh try and reduce Global poverty but it
applies more broadly to any policy is
the randomized experiment to literally
do what we do in medicine all the time
if you want to know if uh if a drug
worked you have you we run a randomized
trial and we look at you know what the
effect is of giving the drug to one
group and not to another one can do the
same thing uh with any policy question I
mentioned earlier we did this uh with
the case of what is what is the effect
of covering low-income uninsured people
with uh Medicaid you can do a randomized
trial this was done in the state of
Oregon in 2008 and Kate Baker and I
studied it in which the state randomly
allocated Medicaid to some low-income
uninsured adults and not to others and
then you can see what happens and I
think it's incredibly important you know
whatever you your theories or your
biases or your hypotheses or your hopes
are to to look at the data uh and learn
from it one of the things uh many people
had claimed was if we expand Medicaid
Health Insurance to previously uninsured
individuals will get these individuals
out of the emergency room where they uh
where they have to be by law be treated
and into cheaper and more effective
primary and preventive care and what we
saw from this randomized controlled
trial is that yes covering the
low-income uninsured with Medicaid does
get them into more primary and
preventive care and they have more
doctor visits their rates of mammograms
go up their rates of you know diabetes
checks for blood sugar checks for their
diabetes go up and yet they also go to
the emergency room more so you know as
we talked about earlier health insurance
makes Medical Care cheaper and one thing
that does is get people to use more of
it whether that's a good thing or a bad
thing we can have a different discussion
about but you know you shouldn't be
arguing for uh health insurance
expansion on the grounds that it's going
to get people out of the emergency room
is there in economics some kind of
active resistance to emphasizing these
kinds of empirical results or just a
recognition that it's hard to tease out
all the causal relationships
a good question I don't know of anyone
who's against
I can't I can't think of why anyone
would be against causal evidence and
causal inference I think the problem is
that often it's really hard and the the
challenges come in is you know how do
you form your your most educated guess
when you don't have rigorous causal
evidence and and there I think you know
reasonable people can take different
approaches I think the other thing
that's hard is you know there are many
well-intentioned people in the world
outside of Economics
um who want who hope for the best who
hope that you know expanding health
insurance can be an easy decision
because it'll not only improve people's
lives but save us money and you know
having to tell people that actually no
there's no free lunch we Face real
trade-offs and it may well be worth it
to spend that money but it's not going
to be free I think there's a lot of
resistance
um in that sense as well from from
well-intentioned people but who who wish
you know that we didn't face as hard
choices as we sometimes do face
okay for the very very final question
then to give the audience a tangible
take-home message
given that you're the World's expert in
all this stuff what kind of insurance do
you have that would be different than
anybody else's like does this actually
make you change your mind about you know
the annual enrollment at MIT when you're
given your options for life insurance
and health insurance and dental
insurance
I well I will say that one thing it
really prompted me to do is to try when
we bought our first home
to get a homeowner's insurance policy
with as high a deductible as possible
the reason being you know Health home
insurance as with most risks is is most
valuable for the for the catastrophic
risk you know your home burns down or a
large section of it is destroyed that's
a real Financial shock and yet you know
despite the rather high price of homes
in the Boston area a lot of a lot of the
homeowners policies you know have a 500
deductible a thousand dollar deductible
I mean that's real money but it's kind
of trivial compared to the cost of a
home and so I searched high and low for
a homeowner's policy with the largest
homeowners deductible you know that I
could find a ten thousand dollar
deductible because the premium was a lot
lower and I I would argue based on the
type of research I do that the reason
the premium was a lot lower is because
people who you know know that there's a
lot of problems with their home and
they're going to have a lot of claims
want to loaded comfortable uh now going
back to supposedly being an insurance
expert I will say that shortly after we
bought this enormous deductible relative
to what you could find policy there was
the winter of 2015 where if you've spent
any time in Massachusetts there was
massive amounts of snow there was it was
declared a Federal Disaster Area
everyone had leaks Etc we got you know
as did everyone we had to get
contractors in to repair the damages and
you know and it we blew well past our
ten thousand dollar deductible the next
year we had a flood in our basement
deductible again and it you know did
cause my long-suffering husband to
observe that it could be quite costly to
be married to an insurance expert
um but but actually he will admit that
if you look over all the years we've had
the policy even with those two you know
big losses the lower premiums we've been
paying every year on the high deductible
policy have in the end paid off enough
you got to do that I once knew a guy who
won a lottery ticket came in with a two
hundred thousand dollar prize and I
asked him how often he bought lottery
tickets tonight is this easy calculation
that he was losing money even if there
had been no taxes at all so wow yeah I
know all right uh good both
intellectually challenging uh socially
important and practically useful
information here so Amy Finkelstein
thanks so much for being on the
mindscape podcast thank you so much for
having me
[Music]
la la la la la